.
DANA?
>> THANK YOU.
>>> THIS MORNING THE ROUTINE
TASK OF FILLING UP YOUR CAR'S
GAS TANK REMAINS DIFFICULT FOR
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS AMID A
SHORTAGE CAUSED BY THE
CYBERATTACK ON THE COLONIAL
PIPELINE.
THE PIPELINE ORIGINATES IN TEXAS
AND CARRIES ABOUT 45% OF THE
FUEL USED ON THE EAST COAST.
THE FBI SAYS THE ATTACK WAS THE
WORK OF DARK SIDE, A SHADOWY
HACKER GROUP THAT DEMANDED AND
GOT WHAT IS BELIEVED TO BE A
MULTIMILLION DOLLAR RANSOM.
FOR MORE ON THE ATTACK AND THE
ONGOING RISK IT HIGHLIGHTS,
WE'RE JOINED BY RETIRED ADMIRAL
MIKE ROGERS, FORMER HEAD OF THE
U.S. CYBER COMMAND.
ADMIRAL, LET ME START WITH IT
SEEMS LIKE THE TWO BASIC
QUESTIONS -- HOW DID THIS
HAPPEN, AND WHAT DID WE LEARN --
SPECIFICALLY LET'S START WITH
HOW DID THIS HAPPEN?
>> SO IN THIS CASE, THIS RUSSIAN
CRIMINAL GROUP, DARK SIDE, WAS
ABLE TO USE MALICIOUS SOFTWARE
PROGRAMS, THEY GAINED ACCESS TO
COLONIAL PIPELINE'S INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY SEGMENT, IF YOU WILL,
AND WERE ABLE TO LOCK IT DOWN,
TO PRECLUDE THE COMPANY'S
ABILITY TO ACCESS THE NETWORK.
AS A RESULT, THE COMPANY IT
APPEARS OPTED TO IN TURN SHUT
DOWN THE PIPELINE OR THE
OPERATIONAL SIDE OF THEIR
BUSINESS TO ENSURE THAT THIS
DIDN'T SPREAD ANY FURTHER.
>> SO ARE THE HACKERS GETTING
MORE SOPHISTICATED, OR ARE
COMPANIES JUST SIMPLY NOT
UPGRADING THEIR SYSTEMS TO WHERE
THEY SHOULD BE?
>> WELL, I WISH I COULD TELL YOU
IT WAS ONLY ONE THING, BUT THE
REALITY IS YOU'RE SEEING AS A
RESULT OF COVID AND THE
DISBURSEMENT OF WORK FORCES FROM
THE WORKPLACE OUT TO THEIR HOMES
AND OTHER AREAS AS WE ARE
CONNECTING MORE AND MORE SYSTEMS
OF A BUSINESS TO THE INTERNET,
AS MORE AND MORE ENTITIES,
CRIMINAL GROUPS START TO ENGAGE
IN RANSOMWARE.
FRANKLY, IT'S BEEN SUCCESSFUL,
AND THEY'RE ABLE TO GENERATE A
LOT OF MONEY.
AS THE LEVEL OF ABILITY OF SOME
OF THESE CRIMINAL ACTORS GROWS,
THE BOTTOM LINE IS YOU'RE SEEING
A MUCH GREATER SUSCEPTIBILITY TO
THIS KIND OF ACTIVITY.
YOU'RE SEEING A MUCH HIGHER
NUMBER OF ACTORS ENGAGED IN THIS
KIND OF ACTIVITY.
THE PROFICIENCY LEVEL OF THOSE
ACTORS JUST KEEPS GROWING.
>> ADMIRAL, THIS WEEK THE
PRESIDENT SIGNED AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER MANDATING MINIMUM
CYBERSECURITY REQUIREMENTS FOR
COMPANIES.
DO YOU THINK THERE SHOULD BE
MORE COLLABORATION BETWEEN THE
GOVERNMENT AND THE PRIVATE
SECTOR?
IS THIS SOMETHING THAT PRIVATE
COMPANIES SHOULD BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR ON THEIR OWN?
>> I THINK, LOOK, IT'S -- IT'S A
CHALLENGE TO ASK A COMPANY, IF
YOU WILL, TO WITHSTAND THE
CONCERTED EFFORTS IN SOME CASES
OF NATION STATES, AND OTHERS AS
A CRIMINAL GROUP.
I THINK IT'S IN OUR NATION'S
BEST INTERESTS TO COLLABORATE,
BUT I WOULD ARGUE WE NEED TO
MOVE BEYOND COLLABORATION AND
MUCH MORE INTO AN INTEGRATED
APPROACH TO HOW WE'RE GOING TO
DO CYBERSECURITY, PARTICULARLY
IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR THAT
IMPACT THE SAFETY AND WELL-BEING
OF OUR CITIZENS, AS WELL AS OUR
ECONOMY, IF YOU WILL.
I THINK IT'S VERY DISAPPOINTING
THAT LITERALLY A WEEK INTO
EVENT, YOU HAD THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ON FRIDAY, YESTERDAY,
SAY, WELL, WE STILL DON'T HAVE
ALL THE DETAILS FROM THE COMPANY
ON EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED.
THAT'S NOT A GOOD PLACE TO BE.
>> IN THIS CASE, IT APPEARS THAT
THE RANSOM WAS PAID, AND THAT
SEEMS TO ALMOST ALWAYS BE THE
CASE.
WHAT IS THE MERIT OF PAYING IT,
AND IS THERE REALLY ANOTHER
OPTION FOR COMPANIES THAT FACE
THIS?
OR GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATIONS?
>> SO BROADLY, I'M NOT A
PROPONENT OF PAYING RANSOM.
NUMBER ONE, THERE'S NO GUARANTEE
THAT IF YOU GIVE IN THIS CASE
THE CRIMINAL GROUP THE MONEY,
THEY'RE ACTUALLY GOING TO UNLOCK
YOUR SYSTEMS.
SECONDLY, THE PAYMENT OF RANSOM
TENDS TO ENCOURAGE OTHERS
BECAUSE THEY'RE ENGAGED IN THIS
ACTIVITY BECAUSE NAY CAN MAKE
MONEY FROM IT.
BUT HAVING SAID THAT, I
ACKNOWLEDGE IT IS NOT AN EASY
DECISION.
YOU'RE A HOSPITAL IN THE MIDDLE
OF A PANDEMIC, AND YOUR SYSTEMS
ARE SHUT DOWN DUE TO A CYBER
HACK.
IT'S A TOUGH CALL TO TELL THEM,
LOOK, WE'LL SHUT IT DOWN, DON'T
PAY THE RANSOM.
THIS SHOWS IN SOME AREAS WE NEED
A TIGHTER AND DIFFERENT
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND THE PRIVATE
SECTOR.
BECAUSE THE GOVERNMENT'S GOT TO
HELP HERE.
>> NOT EASY, BUT WE HAVE GOT TO
FIGU